it's me mr. PewDiePie it's cuckoo Google
Google you call it at last
now tell me tell me about the secret
algorithm you promised
once I hit 50 million you would tell me
everything I need more power
I'm running low Jack step Decay's
catching up I'm falling behind Google
what you want Lily sings on top that's
right I know you don't now that you've
finally made it to 50 million subs you
have access to a super secret higher
level of YouTube heroes YouTube Super
Saiyan God level hero YouTube Super
Saiyan God level hero what is the key
information listen closely to this
information okay the lights they don't
do anything it's a dead button it's been
a dead button all along put the dislikes
what about the dislikes don't you see
that's the key the more dislikes the
more power how do you think so many [ __ ]
channels can rise to the top
ghostbusters
Rebecca Black Justin Bieber VEVO Call of
Duty so you're telling me if I get more
dislikes you will become more powerful
than you could ever imagine it will be
done
[Music]
you would [ __ ] good
1 million death knocks can we smash it
1 million dislikes I'll drown myself
[Music]
1 million dislikes Romania dice 1
million Jeb Bush ah ah
1 million disliked can we get 1 million
gift like 1 million
[Music]
we strike at dawn 1 million dislikes 1
million no no one
[Music]
that one now and guess what
we met 1 million dislikes dis she likes
like [ __ ] like lazy to 1 million huh
no I'll make 1 million deaths
[Music]
all right so apparently likes doesn't
mean [ __ ]
we've been liking videos for nothing
fantastic now it's all about watch time
and making you keep watching more videos
no one really knows what's going on on
YouTube anymore everyone is just testing
out different things begging for likes
oh that guy got a lot of a lot of views
I must beg for likes as well
well apparently likes doesn't even do
anything except dislikes don't forget to
dislike what YouTube one is watch time
and that you watch more videos that's
all they really care about so speaking
of which why don't you check out this
video this is a really great one that I
think you will really enjoy watching cuz
it's very it's practically the same
video as this oh my god I'm getting too
old for this [ __ ]
don't forget to dislike